elena volochine nous rejoint de la
capitale russe elena le kremlin de son
côté se dit satisfait de cette
conversation tout en mettant en garde
contre les sanctions visant la russie ce
serait une erreur colossale
oui selon le conseiller de vladimir
poutine iouri ouchakov cette
conversation de 50 minutes a été
substantielle à l'image finalement je
rapports personnels qu'on établit les
deux présidents russe et américain on
l'a vu cet été à genève un rapport de
considération mutuelle et une volonté de
dialoguer malgré les différents alors
justement cela implique qu'on se dise
les choses est effectivement un job de
nos rêves menacé vladimir poutine de
sanction sans précédent si celui-ci se
décider à attaquer l'ukraine ce à quoi
le président russe aurait répondu que
cela mènerait à une rupture totale des
relations entre moscou et washington joe
biden aurait aussi affirmé qu'en cas d'
attaques russes les états unis
renforcerait les effectifs de l'otan et
augmenterait leur aide militaire à
l'ukraine et c'est précisément ce qu
exige de ne pas faire un moscou dans un
projet d'accord transmis aux états unis
et à l'otan un mi-décembre moscou exige
des garanties de sécurité mutuelle ces
garanties impliquerait que washington et
moscou s'abstiennent de toute manoeuvre
militaire sur le territoire d'un pays
tiers que les signataires de l'accord
considérerait comme une menace pour leur
sécurité
pour ce qui est de l'otan la russie
voudrait que clairement l'alliance
s'engage à ne pas s'élargir dans le
futur y compris à l'ukraine est aussi
l'interdiction faite à l'alliance de
mener toute manoeuvre militaire toute
action militaire sur le territoire des
pays d'europe de l'est du caucase et
d'asie centrale que la russie
traditionnellement dans la lignée de
l'urss considère comme sa zone
d'influencé alors dans ces documents
vladimir poutine marque donc ces lignes
rouges mais elles sont jugées
irrecevables par les états unis côté
américain on les voit tout simplement
comme un nouveau partage de l'europe
après celui qui est intervenu en 45
entre churchill staline et roosevelt à
l'issue de la seconde guerre non elena
volochine cette conversation baden
poutine s'inscrit dans un agenda
diplomatique chargé d'autant plus chargé
que la réalité du terrain est assez
tendue on parle quand même de menaces de
guerre
oui philo mais on voit sur les
nombreuses images satellites qui sont
d'ailleurs en accès libre sur internet à
un impressionnant un impressionnant
pardon déploiement d'artillerie et de
véhicules militaires côté russe coté
frontière ukrainienne est aussi dans la
crim est annexée malgré leur très
officiellement annoncée de 10 mille
soldats qui aurait participé selon le
ministère russe de la défense à des
exercices les blindés l'artillerie sont
toujours là du matériel dernier cri qui
permettrait selon les observateurs de
mener une attaque de grande ampleur par
la russie à leur côté ukrainien il ya
aussi des bombardiers américains qui ont
survolé la mer noire l'ukraine là aussi
renforce ses effectifs ou tout cela
va-t-il mener cela va clairement
dépendre de l'issue des pourparlers à
venir vous le disiez rendez vous est
pris pour les délégations russe et
américaine à genève les 9 et 10 janvier
prochain puis des pourparlers auront
lieu dans le cadre de l'eau et c'est eux
et des pourparlers directs entre la
russie et l'otan le 13 janvier jobs
hayden et vladimir poutine promettent de
suivre et de chapeauter leur délégation
tout au long de ces pourparlers qui
pourrait bien déterminer finalement s'il
y aura ou non bientôt une nouvelle
guerre en europe elena gauche volochine
à moscou merci beaucoup voilà ce qu'on
pouvait dire avec vous à l'heure qu'il
est